6 et moi ok afrique
ok j'ai essayé de résoudre un problème
là voilà c'est grâce à ça que d'ici là
aujourd'hui
ne vous focalisez pas sur ce que vous
êtes aujourd'hui
mais croyez plus tôt en ce que vous
pouvez réaliser aujourd'hui c'est une
notion de vie que je t'y de oxo pas qu
il y as autour de noms assez de
problèmes qui minent notre entourage la
société notre pays et face à tous ces
problèmes
il a également deux types de regard
assez fréquent il ya ceux qui se disent
je peux pas le faire j'ai pas la
capacité
j'ai pas les moyens j'ai pas le moyens
intellectuels de le réaliser
[Musique]
l'autre peut le faire l'autre cas les
moyens peut le faire mais jamais mois et
d'un autre schéma il ya 7 1 qui se
disent espère qu'ils ont des expertises
en résolution de problèmes mais jamais
qui apporte une solution vraiment viable
il semble résoudre le problème mais dans
le fond ne le resort jamais à ce niveau
je me souviens d'une parole du premier
président ivoirien félix bwanika dit on
ne veut pas des chercheurs qui cherchent
mais des chercheurs qui trouvent
je suis sa belle série
j'ai 23 ans nettement depuis 20 moins de
trois ans maintenant je vous parlais
d'une partie de ma vie qui a bouleversé
toute mon histoire en 2011
cette année là j'avais 17 ans après
avoir échoué au baccalauréat de 1 point
j'étais vraiment désespérée pour ceux
qui ont déjà échoué en examen isaf et
vos mots désespéré et cette année là
j'avais décidé de retourner au village
rencontré mon grand-père passer des
vacances changer un peu d'air et
approuvé ni sur abidjan ivoire
quelle orientation ma vie allait prendre
et c'est comme ça lors de ses vacances
une fois j'étais allé au chant de la
plantation de mon grand-père et la
veille il avait plu je me suis rendu
compte que la pluie qui était tombée la
veille avec gâcher carrément toute la
production du caoutchouc naturel et donc
quand je suis rentré au village et du
g10 au vieux mais j'ai constaté quelque
chose dans sa plantation c'est qu'il n'y
a même pas de production aujourd'hui à
cause de la pluie
c'est normal il m'a répondu mon enfant
c'est comme ça dans ce flou et donc
lorsqu'il m'a dit ça je lui ai dit ok et
c'est comme ça il a consommé expliquer
tout ce qui se passait en saison des
pluies au niveau de la récolte de livia
il se trouve que les saisons plus vieux
sont les saisons les plus favorables a
récolté via parce que labrie tropicale
est donc là bas à l'occasion la
possibilité d'absorber beaucoup d'eau et
donc produit beaucoup plus de latex et
sous-produits le latex
il ya généralement des personnes qu'on
appelle les seniors dévia qui vont et
qu'il faut une décision sur le tronc de
l'arbre et cela laisse couler une scène
qu'on appelle la thèse qui sous forme
liquide et cette sève à son passé dans
la tasse que vous voyez là sous forme
l'équipe pendant une demi-journée ou
voir une journée avant de se solidifier
mais dans ce laps de temps s'il pleut
les eaux de pluie qui ruisselle sur le
tronc de livia hissel qui retombe des
feuilles vont s'accumuler dans cette
place est donc imaginer que vous avez
une petite tasse et que vous mettez une
pluie de l'air et vous ajoutez une
carafe d'eau il n'y a plus de lait dans
la tasse c'est ce qui se passe là et
donc toute la production se gâche en
saison des pluies et auparavant les
planteurs il avait
recours à des produits chimiques et une
foire en contact avec le latex du soul
duffy automatiquement
mais ce produit il a été refusé parce
que il accélère la rouille au niveau des
machines industrielles et donc ça les
endommagent et donc les planteurs ont
demandé main pour mon peut faire pour
résoudre le problème si on peut plus
utiliser ce produit et laurent dit mais
calculer le temps si vous calculez su
wei qu'il pleuve ou n'essayez pas s'ils
voient qu'il pleuve ou n'essayez pas y
ait des plus pas vous saignez est donc
l'un dans l'autre ce problème était
resté à ce niveau jusqu'au jour où j'ai
parlé avec mon grand père est un soir en
rentrant du champ j'ai regardé
attentivement sa plantation
je veux si tu y vas set aussi il suffit
de consulter un petit objet en plastique
on place le train de l'est via il se
protège c'est tout et quand je suis
rentré à la maison je lui ai dit bon
voilà j'ai trouvé une paire 6 1 pour toi
il m'a dit non tu doit dessiner
tu dois faire un plan tu dois faire si
tu dois faire cela je lui ai dit c'est
trop long et dit vas-y faut le faire et
c'est comme ça ensemble on a réalisé
on a fait des dessins industriels on a
essayé de trouver les this man
dimensions qui s'adaptait mais jusque là
il y avait toujours des problèmes
si vous suivez le cours de l'histoire
pour que j'ai l'idée de réaliser ça il
fallait que j'écoute
il fallait que j'observe le problème
avec mon grand père mais lorsque je suis
revenu cieux abidjan j'ai voulu réaliser
le prototype sans toutefois me
rapprocher de ceux qui étaient concernés
et donc on a fait plusieurs lycées ça ne
fonctionnait pas ça n'arrivait pas à
s'adapter à tous les troncs et donc nous
sommes retourné vers les planteurs et en
retournant vers eux
nous avons essayé de réaliser des tout
est un dispositif manuel et on a pris en
considération toutes les attentes
pour certains ils ont posé la
préoccupation des ponts qui sont penchés
vers l'arrière vers l'avant
donc il fallait trouver une forme qui
pouvait ouvrir la task que sur la
direction que la prend en même temps il
y en a d'autres qui ont posé la
condition de la pied mais il y a deux
qui sont gros donc est-ce qu'il faut
fait en même temps fallait mettre sur le
dispositif
un système qui permettait aux
dispositifs d adapter à tous les troncs
divia
il y en a d'autres qui ont parlé de
l'eau qui ruisselle sur le tronc qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire à ce niveau
alors on a décidé de mettre un système
d'étanchéité qui pouvait permettre de
stopper tout l'eau qui ruisselle sur le
tronc de cela j'ai tiré une grande leçon
c'est que par moments nous avons des
problèmes que nous voulons résoudre mais
nous non nous n'allons jamais vers ceux
qui ont ces problèmes souvent observer
écouter et poser l'action avec ceux qui
ont ce problème peut vous permettre de
trouver une meilleure solution et ce
dispositif il est le seul dispositif le
plus autonomes en matière de solutions
de protection de la tasse le plus
autonome pour les planteurs d'hévéa
à la suite de cela nous avons postulé à
des compétitions
nous avons eu en 2015 depuis passe reste
du meilleur jeune inventeur ivoiriens
nous avons été sélectionnés parmi les
dix meilleurs jeunes innovateurs
africains et donc je devais porter le
nom du pays au niveau africain et nous
avons remporté d'autres prier même fait
la une du célèbre magazine comme tout
bon au mag magazine de jeunesse
il n'est pas donné à tout le monde
c'était un honneur lors de ma sélection
parmi les dix meilleurs jeunes
innovateurs il y à l'africaine ovation
fondation qui m'a invité au botswana et
lorsque je suis arrivé au botswana je ne
retrouvais pas me désespère désespère en
innovation désespère développement
technologies des ventes europe et le
plus grands inventeurs africain et je me
retrouver là au milieu d'eux il y en a
un qui me disait ni format 10 x
my friend of france and julia my friend
camille au canyon elles sont toutes les
questions des droits
tu mets pas une photo avec moi d'accord
et donc tout heureux j'appuie la photo
pour cete ça peut paraître assez c'est
un peu faire une photo avec un grand
inventeur mais lorsqu'on sait
quel type de vente et a ramené une
aventure qui est parti de rien aussi au
mans c'est une grande joie prônons le
système scolaire m'avait écarté parce
que je n'arrive pas à trouver ma place
dans le système scolaire
j'ai lutté mais je me suis pas sorti
j'ai vu au bac 2 1 points ce n'est pas
seulement le système scolaire qui
m'avait écart ap mais il y avait
également le système social je vais vous
raconter une petite histoire qui vous
permettra de comprendre en quelques en
quelques minutes les conditions sociales
dans lesquelles j'ai fait quand j'étais
en sixième
j'étudiais un soir je vivais dans une
maison sans eau sans courant avec ma
mère et j'ai tu t'es bien évidemment à
l'aide d'une bougie
c'était en 2006 et pendant que
j'étudiais reçoit jusqu'à minutes
j'étudiais j'étudiais et en étudiant
j'ai senti de la fumée
comme si quelqu'un y tintin puisque
j'aime beaucoup le village donc j'essaie
cambrai un animal j'essaie donc j'ai
conscience senti de la fumée je me suis
dit mais c'est qu'il voisine qui braises
de la viande abouti à minuit ça c'est ce
n'est pas que ses voisins 8 de monde
mais je continue à étudier est arrivé un
moment j'ai comme ça senti une forte
chaleur au niveau de ma tête j'y suis
comme ça on est allé tester mes cheveux
du double
et ce jour là lorsque je me suis assis
je me suis agressif et j'ai fait un long
soupir et je continue à étudier
lorsque ce don inventé au nigeria ma
demande et nigeria m'a demandé de faire
la photo avec lui ses deux soupirs que
je me suis souvenu
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui plus que jamais je sias
attaché à cette citation que j'ai faite
lorsque j'avais 14 ans je ne vais pas
faire partie de ceux qui passent dans le
monde mais plutôt de ceux qui marquent
le monde résoudre un problème ne
nécessite pas forcément une grande
expertise aider quelqu'un nous n'avons
pas besoin de prendre un long moment
pour le faire il vous suffit juste
d'observer d'écouter d'essayer au moins
d'agir et nous allons deviennent des
personnes qui ont réussi à changer la
vie d'une deux trois tas de personnes et
sa propre fille en velin était mon grand
père à résoudre son problème
je me retrouvais en train de résoudre
deux problèmes où tous les planteurs
d'hévéa de la côte d'ivoire de l'afrique
et même du monde
c'est pourquoi le tennier la dernière
phrase que je vais vous laisser ses
dream creed the new world
because it is possible is not in the
world eats dream prix hunting your world
because he n'est plus possible
[Applaudissements]